ici sur le lacos Cisco le pêcheur Guy La
Rochelle vient taquiner le poisson au
pied de la fonderie Horn il utilise
comme appât un marcheur de fond ça c'est
une bonne méthode pour le doré le
gouvernement recommande de ne pas manger
plus de deux repas de doré par mois
provenant de ce lac contrairement aux
autres lacs de la région une étude de
2015 indique que les concentrations de
métaux lourds dans les sédiments du
lacos Cisco dépasse les concentrations
recommandées pour protéger les
organismes aquatiques c'est un résidu
qui ressemble à une poussière noire qui
est très très solide dans l'eau il y a
un an à peu près 30 cm d'épée mais si on
pense notre mail là-dedans ça va se
disputer comme un nuage Radio-Canada a
parcouru plusieurs études portant sur
l'impact sur la faune et la flore de la
fonderie Horn propriété de Glenn des
chercheurs se sont penchés sur le lichen
l'étude démontre que l’accumulation des
métaux lourds dans le lichen est en
cours et non seulement le résultat du
passé le plomb retrouver à des niveaux
150 fois plus élevés à proximité de la
fonderie que ce qu'on a retrouvé à 50 km
dans le bois il en va aussi du nickel et
du cadmium dont on retrouve des traces
jusqu'à 50 km à l'est ça nous aiguille
sur le fait que ça vient des
probablement de la fonderie mais
assurément de la ville de rouynoranda Le
conseil en environnement de la Région
souhaite que le gouvernement accentue
les exigences quant aux contaminant
rejeté par la mine elle est seulement
normée au niveau de l'arsenic mais pour
tous les autres
contaminants métaux lourds et pour les
terres rares actuellement rien qui n'est
prévu et ça fait pas partie du réseau de
surveillance en 45 ans Yves et ses
partenaires de chasse ont tué 45 bêtes
ils se sont eux qui éviterèrent leur
proie quand le fouet des petites taches
blanches
au Québec il n'est pas recommandé de
manger les abats de rignal reconnu pour
être contaminés aux cadmium selon une
étude réalisée en 2013 les orignaux dans
un rayon de 50 km autour de la fonderie
ont des concentrations beaucoup plus
élevées de canyon dans les reins que les
autres serviés ailleurs au Québec et
même dans le monde les rejets passés de
la fonderie sont suspectés dans naître
l'origine Glenn explique qu'au fil des
décennies plusieurs projets ont permis
d'améliorer le bilan environnemental un
plan d'action majeur pour réduire les
émissions atmosphériques sera déposée en
nous un changement de cap
environnemental est exigé pour la mine
poumon économique de la région j'ai
confiance aussi que ça va se faire avec
la mine puis avec tout le monde
alentours dans la région pour que l'on
puisse un jour se baigner à nouveau dans
le lacos Cisco
ici Marie José Paquette como
Radio-Canada Rouyer